[MUSIC PLAYING]
CRAIG BOX: Good
morning, everybody.
Thank you for coming
along to a talk today.
Want to tell you
about how we improve
utilization and portability of
applications using containers.
My name is Craig.
I'm an advocate for the
Google Cloud platform,
focused on IT professionals,
and also dev ops.
It's great to be here on a
fantastic warm, sunny day
in San Francisco.
But because I've come over
from London with my girlfriend,
we're going to spend
the weekend in Yosemite.
And we thought we needed to pack
our snow boots just in case.
Her boots didn't
fit in her suitcase.
But I had lots of
empty space in mine.
So we put her boots in
the bag, and put them
inside my suitcase.
So I've increased the
utilization of my suitcase.
And by doing that, that
means we don't actually
have to pay to take
another bag with us.
You can tell I'm probably
not hipster enough for those
are my actual suitcases.
But also in saying that,
I'm not the kind of person
who's going to vacuum
pack my shirts,
so that I can fit
more in my suitcase.
But if you are the airport, and
you're moving thousands of bags
around every minute, being able
to pack more into your trucks
does actually save
you a lot of money.
We, of course, have a
very similar problem
with the computers
here at Google.
Every new computer
we add costs money.
But we have more computers
than most people do.
So we want to pack more
things onto fewer machines
and improve the
utilization of them.
So by building a system that
allows computers to decide how
to do the packing,
rather than people,
we found that, for example, we
could run our batch workloads,
like building the search
index for Google.com,
into the empty space on
the same set of machines
that run our serving workloads,
like serving you 10 blue links
when you go to do a search.
And we've estimated
that at the time--
and this was a few years ago--
just that one thing, being
able to pack the batch
into the empty space saved
us the cost of building
an entire Google data center.
These are fantastic buildings.
But as you can imagine,
they don't come cheap.
How do we do this?
We need to move away from
managing individual machines
to managing fleets
of applications
running on containers.
So first of all, a quick
refresh on virtual machines
and containers because a lot
of the workloads that people
want to move to cloud today and
into containers start on VMs.
So we want to look at a recap
of the strengths and weaknesses
of the two platforms.
Ultimately, I like to
think of a container
as just being a process with
some restrictions on what it
can and can't do.
If you think of an
app on your phone,
it's a very close analogy
to a Linux container.
If you turn on your phone, you
start the operating system.
It's booting a machine.
It takes around about 60 seconds
from cold to get to the point
where you can use, any computer
really, but phones even so.
Starting a process is just
launching an application.
If you don't have it yet,
then you have to download it.
It takes a few seconds.
But when you do
have it, it should
take milliseconds to launch.
It should be imperceptible
in the most case.
Now for a lot of reasons, the
applications on your phone
are only allowed to
do a subset of things.
You want to restrict
an app, for example,
not to be able to download
your entire contact list
and send it out, and
[? use ?] something.
The permissions you
set are about what
you want to grant a
particular application to do.
And similarly, Linux containers
have restrictions set on them
to what they can and
can't do, especially
with regard to the resources
that they can see and use
on the machines that
they're running on.
Now some of the characteristics
of virtual machines
cause us to have
lower utilization.
For example, in this case, we
have a host operating system.
But in our three VMs, we
run three redundant copies
of a guest OS.
In that image, we
coupled in the libraries
that relate to the
particular operating system
that we're running.
And therefore, the
apps that we run
use those system libraries
in a tight coupling.
And even though we
have some free space
available on all three of
the virtual machines running
on this particular host, if we
want to run something that is,
say, three units
big, in this case,
we can't do that because the
space is stranded across three
different machines.
Now containers abstract away the
operating system, first of all,
so that you, as a developer,
all you have to think about
is your own application and the
libraries that it needs to run.
You think, also,
about the interfaces
with the other applications
you want to run.
And if we only had one machine
that never failed and never ran
out of resources, that
would be all that we needed.
Because we run on
more than one machine,
and we want to be able
to scale horizontally,
we invented Kubernetes--
which is derivative of
our internal systems,
but developed as open source--
to abstract away
everything else that you
might need to think about in
a multi-machine environment,
which we call a cluster.
So scheduling
containers is one part.
But other things, like
keeping your containers
alive and healthy, grouping
them together into the services
that you actually want to
run, connecting traffic
to those services, handling,
logging, and monitoring,
and identify and
authorization, these
are all things that we feel,
as an application developer,
the system should
provide for you.
Now those things
make up two legs
of what we've come
to call cloud native.
So container packaging
gives you predictability
of deployment and efficient
resource isolation.
So you're just
copying a file when
you're deploying
a container that
contains all of the
resources, libraries
that your application needs.
Next is the dynamic
scheduling-- which is, again,
provided by Kubernetes--
that allows higher quality
of service and efficiency
by being able to have
the computer decide
where to place these workloads.
And that means that you can
do more with fewer humans
and have a lower
operations cost.
Now the final leg
of cloud native
is microservices oriented.
And that talks more to
the re-usability of code,
and independently developed
applications, and sort
of domain-driven
development as much
as it talks of loose coupling.
It's not necessarily
something that everyone
will do as they move
their apps to the cloud.
But it's something
to think about
for your newer applications.
So I want to talk
through a few use cases
from both a business and
a technical perspective.
For example, what do you
think the most common cause
of outages is?
Do you think it's people
writing bad software?
It turns out that it's
actually people deploying
misconfigured software.
And it's especially
the case when
you have the kind of bad
outages that bring everything
down at once.
We find that we're
seeing studies
with over 50% of outages caused
by bad configuration pushes.
Another point, our
friends at Ticketmaster
have estimated that simply
the action of moving code
around and deploying it
into their environments
was a $60 to $90 million
a year problem for them,
the amount of
resource and people
and machinery required
to deploy code
across hundreds of different
bespoke systems that they run.
And ultimately, this leads to
questions like, why can't we
move quickly?
Why are these
deployments failing?
And why are we having to run
servers at 20% utilization
when we're wasting and
stranding all this excess space?
We need to know that our
deployments will succeed.
So I want to talk about how we
can solve some of these things
with a cloud native approach.
Now I think there are
three distinct changes
that you need to think about
if you're going to this move.
Just as cloud native
has three legs,
we have these three
distinct migrations
with individual characteristics.
So you can move to containers
without thinking about any
of the dynamic scheduling.
You can just deploy a single
container on a single machine
and treat them like an RPM or
a package of some description.
That's a perfectly
valid thing to do.
The other end, you could choose
to run everything in VMs.
You can run clustered
applications.
You don't actually
need to worry about--
we think a container's a
great format for clustering.
But there are other
approaches that you can run.
Now cloud native doesn't
actually require cloud.
You can take those
first two things
and run in your own environment,
move your application
to container clusters,
and run it on premise.
And we think that's
a fantastic thing
to do because when it comes
time to move to cloud,
you'll find that all the hard
work has been done for you.
Makes your application portable.
And we want to talk about
some specific workloads
and what that might look like.
First of all, a
three-tier application,
we quite often think of a
presentation, or web front end,
some sort of middleware,
and some sort of database.
In this particular environment,
we've already made separation.
We have a distinct, clear
contract between these layers.
And it's quite often a network
communication as it stands.
So it's easy to scale
them out independently.
And so if you have a
workload like this,
it's a really good candidate
to be the first thing
that you move, for the
first two tiers, at least.
We're going to talk about
databases separately
in a minute.
The batch jobs are another
great use case because
of their burstable nature.
If you can pack your batch
work into containers,
then you can schedule
them only when
your cluster has free space,
as we talked about with Google
Search earlier.
There are package
management options now
for running things like
Spark on top of Kubernetes.
And if you want to run
clustered batch processing
stuff on Google, you
also have hosted options
like Cloud Dataflow
and Cloud Dataproc.
And both of those
things will let
you take a Docker
container, and use it
as the unit of processing
that you do on your data.
So again, these two things
can be decoupled and used
separately.
Now a lot of people
talk about something
which we call carving the
monolith, which is an industry
term for taking a
single, giant application
and breaking it up
into microservices.
For more traditional
workloads, I
like to think you can apply the
same logic to virtual machines.
Kubernetes has a
concept of a pod, which
is the unit of scheduling.
It's not just an
individual container,
but it's containers that
tightly couple together
that need to be scheduled
at the same time
and need to communicate
with each other.
And this lets you break down
your work into containers
where it makes sense.
And you don't need to pack
two different things that
are sort of built by different
teams into the same container,
have them maintain them,
connect them together in a pod,
and then you can deploy them
on different life cycles.
And eventually,
that just moves you
towards a microservices
implementation.
But if you have VMs today where
you use something like Puppet,
for example, to deploy
a bunch of things,
you think about how
we can break them down
to individual containers
and then map them to a pod.
Now databases are a
very contentious topic.
There's a popular meme
saying you probably shouldn't
run databases in containers.
But remember that
all the container is
is a Linux process
with some restrictions
about what it can and can't do.
So again, think about the
difference between containers
and clusters.
It is possible to run
Oracle on top of Docker.
Oracle even published
images on GitHub
that let you build
containers to run this.
It's possible that you
don't want these dynamically
scheduled and just moved
around your environment
at will because you actually
need to connect them up
to the data that backs them.
But there are more modern,
more cloud native databases
that support this kind
of clustering themselves.
So the way I look about
this, it pays to ask,
do I get value out
of being a DBA?
Think about it this way.
If you know how to scale the
database, how to back it up,
how it deals in
cluster partitions,
network failures,
and you know how to do all the
same thing with a cluster, yes,
it is absolutely possible to
take a traditional database--
something that's
not cluster aware--
and run it on top of Kubernetes.
If you're dealing with
a commercial vendor,
they might not like
you doing this.
They might say, well, that's
not a supported environment.
I'm not really happy about that.
We'd rather you run on VMs.
And that's OK.
Because you can just run
those VMs next to your cluster
and call out to them.
With open source databases,
you sort of weigh up the pros
and cons of hosted services--
and you've all seen that we
announced our hosted PostgreSQL
service in the keynote this
morning--
versus running your own.
And with our hosted
service, there
are some extensions that
we just don't provide,
that you may need to run custom.
And there may well
be specific-use cases
where it does make
sense to run your own.
And my colleagues from Samsung
will talk about that in a bit.
Patterns and helpers for running
these databases on Kubernetes
are coming thick and
fast from the community.
Vitess, what you see there
on the logo on the left,
is a new application
developed by YouTube
which makes it possible to
scale MySQL horizontally.
It works well on Kubernetes.
It a great way of running
MySQL in a way that
is aware of the
clustered environment
where workloads can
move and change.
But remember, it's
not all or nothing.
It's still OK to use VMs.
You can use the service
abstraction in Kubernetes
to refer to things outside your
cluster, as well as inside it.
If you do have a workload
where locality is important,
where you want to make sure
it's tied to a physical machine
that has a card, or a GPU,
or a license and dongle,
for example.
Or if you already run
something that's commercial
and has cluster
manager in its name,
chances are you'll want to
keep those things separate.
And because we have both
container and VM platforms,
it's easy to make that choice.
OK, we've made some choices
about what applications
we want to move.
The first step is
actually putting them
inside a container.
So for applications that you
build yourself internally,
the easiest thing
to do is just take
the output from your
current build system--
in this case, we have an RPM--
and then write a little
script or Dockerfile
to build a container
based on installing
that on top of an image
that already has legs on it.
So in this case here, you'll see
we just copy in an application
that we've built. We
take a centos image.
We update it.
We install any of
the dependencies
that we need for
that application.
We run the RPM.
And we instruct
it, when it starts,
this is the application
that I want to run.
That's really all it takes
to get a container that
runs an application.
It's probably going to
be bigger than you want,
because you're dragging
in a lot of things.
But it will work.
And it will do what
you need to do.
The next step is changing how
you package your application.
So if we're just building an RPM
for the privilege of installing
it in a Docker container, we
don't really need that RPM.
We should just build the
Docker container directly.
So we make whatever changes we
need here in this pseudo code
build script.
We'll check out the application,
build the release binaries.
And now instead of calling
the step to build an RPM,
we could say, take that
directory of output,
and then build a
Docker container
from a file which is on top
of a generic Linux operating
system, whatever it
is that you need,
install and run these files.
Now that's fantastic
when we start
looking at continuous
integration tools.
So all modern CI systems
can build containers.
This is Jenkins here.
It's very easy to get to a
world where you commit a change
and have a container
automatically built.
And the great
thing about Jenkins
is that you can use
the clusters that you
have to provide the compute
to run the builders that
build the containers that will
then go run on these clusters.
So you can use the
empty space, again,
to increase the utilization
of the machines that you have.
Alternatively, this week we've
launched Google Cloud Container
Builder, which is a hosted
service for building container
images in the cloud.
So again you have a choice,
do I just connect this up
so it can watch for
pushes to GitHub,
and then automatically build
containers, and put them
into my secure registry?
Or is there something that
I want to run yourself?
You always have that
trade-off between the things
you want to manage versus
taking on a managed service.
And I do encourage you
to have a look at that.
So with no changes
to the code at all,
we've gone from a situation
where people say, ah, well,
it worked on my machine.
Why doesn't it
work in production?
And it's so hard to deploy.
And rolling back
is very difficult,
to having an artifact
which runs the same any way
you run sitting on top of
the container run time.
You just start the
container using a command
like Docker run to deploy it.
And then if you need to
roll back to an old image,
all you need to do is
restart the old image.
You have them both there.
You don't have to think, oh,
I've upgraded the machine.
I now have to downgrade
it again-- or worse,
redeploy the entire machine--
to do a safe rollback.
Now let's look at
the clustering.
So if you remember the
title of this session,
the two things we're
looking for are
utilization and portability.
So we'll take what we have
that runs on a single machine
and move it to run in a
multi-machine clustered
environment.
The first thing I
suggest is if you
haven't read "The Twelve-Factor
Manifesto" recently, do go back
and have a look at it.
It was published
a few years ago.
But it really
boils down the idea
that to run these
scalable applications led
to the development
of cloud native.
Your applications are probably
missing a few of these steps.
So for example,
Twelve-Factor says
that the configuration
for your application
should be provided by the
environment that they run on,
rather than packed
into these containers.
You don't want to have to
build a different image
to run in your
development environment
to run in production.
What you should do is just
say, in that container,
fetch from an
environment variable--
or as a command line
flag, for example--
the configuration.
And then have the
environment provide that.
In the Kubernetes case,
we have an abstraction
called Secrets, which
are abstractions
for simple credential
management.
We also have config
maps, which are a way
to parse configuration
into environments.
And if you want, you can connect
up to more complex things
like a [? hasher ?] called
Vault, or our Cloud Key
Management Service,
to provide credentials
and your applications, things
you definitely should not
be checking into
GitHub, for example.
Given that we now have our
code and our configuration,
the next thing we want to do is
actually deploy an application.
So we'll create a
deployment object.
And that will
create a replica set
with all of the pods
having the same metadata.
And we just specify how
many replicas we want.
We should make that choice based
on the resource requirements.
And we encourage
you to test what
it is that you get when you have
a certain amount of CPU and RAM
per container because we want
to set those limits to make sure
that we don't run away with all
the free space in the cluster.
Then we create a
service, which groups
those pods together,
and potentially connect
that to something like an NGRES
to get inbound traffic in.
And now we have our container
application inside our cluster
receiving traffic and serving.
Having done all that, all of
these things are API-driven.
So we can lead to a
world where all of this
is done automatically for us.
We can do continuous delivery
where you push your change.
It gets built. It gets tested.
Perhaps there's a
human approval step.
And then the deployment
is done to the cluster.
And first, we'd like to use the
tool called Spinnaker, which
we've worked with Netflix,
who built this tool initially
as an enhancement on their
work on VM-based deployments.
And we've especially
collaborated with them around
being able to do Kubernetes in
container-based deployments.
But again, the APIs
are there, so you
can tie this into whatever
continuous delivery
system you use.
Or you can even run this from
the cloud container builder,
and just have a step
that does deployment.
Now if you're running a common
application, the open source
databases, for example, you
think, well, I don't actually
need to go through
the effort of building
all of these containers myself.
Someone else has
probably done that.
And then I can just
reuse their work.
So there's a package
manager for Kubernetes,
which is called Helm.
It contains many
open source packages
that are ready to deploy.
But it's also an
engine you can use
to describe how your
containers, and your pods,
and services relate to each
other in an environment,
and then use that
as the thing that
gets deployed on your cluster.
So similar to how a package
manager, like Docker RPM,
for example, installs the
thing on a single machine,
Helm brings that up
a level, and says,
install this on the
cluster wherever
it happens to need to be.
So when we would think about
anything that handles states,
we need to think about storage.
Traditionally,
what we would do is
we would have some
large set of disks,
and a computer attached to them
that runs to the database that
serves that data.
You'd say that the
work follows the state.
Now we're talking about
distributed clusters
in Kubernetes.
You should think about turning
that around, and saying,
the state follows the work.
So wherever your database
engine gets scheduled,
the state is just
attached by way
of taking a network disk that
contains that, putting it
on the right machine
automatically
as a volume, which is
then mapped into that pod.
If you think of a
use case where you
have a number of
different nodes which
run a set of replicas
for a database,
they all have slightly
different data,
depending on what's
[? shouted ?] on each one.
And instead of just having a
replica set with each thing
having the same
data attached to it,
we now have an abstraction
called a stateful set, which
lets you say, this particular
replica has disk zero, replica
zero, disk one, replica
one, for example--
map through to the number
that you need to have.
And it's a great way for
running these stateful workloads
on top of Kubernetes.
Where am I going
to store this data?
The great thing
about Kubernetes is
that you don't need to
think about the abstraction
below as someone who is
simply deploying and running
applications.
Kubernetes abstracts
away the physicality
of the parts, the sort of
below the imaginary line.
It might be that, in
your own data center,
you have network disks
attached by iSCSI.
If you run OpenStack, you
might use the Cinder plugins.
And on cloud, we have network
attachable persistent disks.
So all you do is say,
Kubernetes, give me a volume.
Or you have a volume provision
by your administrator.
And it is backed by whatever is
available in your environment.
So again, you don't have to
write different code to run
in different environments.
So you end up with
an application
which is eminently portable
because of that consistent API.
Same is true of network.
How am I going to
get incoming traffic?
Well, it might be that I have
physical load balances that
might require a network
team or someone to program
before they work in my
physical environment.
But in the cloud
environment, I might just
be able to make an API call, and
then have that wired up for me.
The same things that are
true of these abstractions
are both storage and networking.
Now that comes in
very handy when
we get to step three in our
three-step process, which is
actually moving to the cloud.
In the simplest
case, we just take
the Kubernetes
configuration files
that we've built,
that we were running
on our on-premise environment,
we point our command line tool
to a cloud environment.
And we do exactly
the same thing.
It sounds flippant,
but I actually
sat down with a customer
at home in London.
And we said, let's get your
app running on Google Container
Engine.
It took them longer
to figure out
how to get their
laptop connected back
to remote into their desktop
from the conference room,
and then figure out what
environment variables they'd
set wrong, which meant that
none of the commands would run,
than it did to actually get
their environment running
on the cloud.
That's the magic of possibility.
Now, of course,
there is more to it
than this, because you need to
synchronize your data, as well.
And you need to generally have a
hybrid environment where you're
running while that
process is happening
across multiple places.
We're working on that
Federated API servers,
so we have the facility
to have clusters
that run in different places
managed in the same way.
And then it really
just comes up to you
to be able to handle
the migration of data
by whichever way makes the
most sense for whatever it
is that you're running.
So stateless workloads,
you don't necessarily
have any data to migrate.
But when we start talking
about storage, you do.
So now I'd like to
invite our guests
from Samsung SDS, who are going
to talk through a migration
that they did.
Bob Wise is the group's CTO.
And he's going to talk
a little bit about how
customers decide when to move.
And again, if
you're a developer,
this is something you can
take back to your boss,
and say, these are things that
we really need to think about,
and that will let me do
these cool deployments.
And then Lee Chang is
a senior architect.
And he's going to talk
about the technical details
of the particular
migration that they did.
So thank you very much to Bob.
[APPLAUSE]
BOB WISE: I think there
is a lot of good material
in those slides.
Hopefully, we'll be able
to help you instantiate
a bit by going through
a real-life example
that we've been working on.
So Lee and I work for Samsung
SDS, the Cloud Native Computing
team.
So what does that mean?
I should say, first of
all, even though I'm
on the board of the
CNCF, and our group
is all about cloud
native, there's
something I don't like about
the cloud native word, which
is it has this strong
implication that you have
to build things from scratch,
that they have to be natively
engineered and designed
for that kind of cloud
native environment.
And we don't
believe that's true.
And the example that we're
going to talk about today
is a great example
of how is it that you
can take existing
applications and migrate them
without a lot of re-architecture
into this new world.
So there's a few
things we believe
that are very important.
We are obsessive
about automation.
That's an important piece
of being cloud native.
We're very dedicated,
and believe
that open source is really where
infrastructure is being built.
And we're motivated by being
involved in that community.
Within Samsung Group, we
work with various teams
to help them with
their transformations.
But we also have an
outside business.
And Lee's going to have a little
bit longer part of the talk.
We're going to talk about one
of our customers engagements.
A couple of things we're
going to talk about--
so I talked about cloud
native a bit already.
I want to introduce this term
cluster ops, which you're
going to start hearing more,
which is this new term that's
trying to capture that there
are some new things that are
happening, not just
with the technology,
but with the organization.
How do companies organize
properly around this?
They will frequently
need some help
because this is a
big transformation.
The thing that companies get
out of this kind of cloud
native work is,
although, you can
use Kubernetes and
Containers to make
much more efficient use of
your infrastructure, most
companies--
Google might be an
example that spends
enormous amounts of money
on their infrastructure.
But most companies spend
more money on their people.
And it's much more important
to have great product
velocity and high quality.
The kind of infrastructure
optimization
is a less important priority.
So cluster ops is three things.
How do you manage
your infrastructure?
How do you manage your org?
How do you manage your tooling?
Deep embedded in that concept
is the notion of an SRE.
And now we're getting
into these kind
of more complex
organizational topics that
are part of what we help with.
So we do executive consulting.
We do professional
services for migration.
And we help companies
adopt cluster ops.
So we've been contributors
involved in the Kubernetes
community for a long
time at this point.
We were on stage with Google
for the Kubernetes 1.0 launch.
We made a very early bet.
Why did we make that bet?
Was it a good bet?
So, yes, it was a great bet.
Kubernetes has become the
fastest-growing, best-supported
orchestration system out there.
It has the best options
for multi-cloud.
Craig mentioned that.
And it's open source.
Open source is good,
but it also comes
with some commitment that's
required in order to really
adopt it well.
And if you're going to use
open source the way we do,
deep industry participation
is really important.
So the way we do that
is we're involved
in helping run the
Kubernetes SIGs.
I'm on the CNCF board.
We have contributors
on the team.
Now some of our customers don't
have the time, the energy,
the capacity to be
engaged at that level.
And this is a way that we help.
So I'll also do a quick mention,
if you go to our GitHub,
we do all of our work
in open source, as well.
We have a project
called K2, which
is a lot of the provisioning
management tooling
that we built around Kubernetes.
So what drives an
enterprise-wide transformation?
So Craig mentioned that
if you're a developer,
come talk to us.
We can help you figure
out how to do this.
But probably most
of our engagement--
and that is help we provide.
How do you understand how to
explain this to your boss?
What's going to be the
effect on the organization?
Do you need validation
that companies like Samsung
are using this technology?
Most of our engagement,
though, go top down,
where the C-suite is
starting to wonder, well,
why do I feel like my
competitors are going faster
than I am?
Can we save money with
container packing?
Do I have a modern team?
Do people really
want to work here
because we're using the best
and most modern technology?
And why is it that it seems
like other people are growing
faster as I read about it?
So consultants will come in.
It's pretty easy
to find consultants
that will come in and help
you with this kind of problem.
And most consulting
groups will offer
a couple of solutions straight
out of the consulting 101
playbook.
Build a massive parallel team.
Let's help you hire some new
leadership into your team.
Let's completely
re-architect the system.
This was my slight objection
to the cloud native term.
But we've taken a
different approach.
I would say, the way I would
characterize our approach,
generally, is an
ops-first approach.
It's frequent that we
see agile transformation
kinds of projects
go a bit sideways
because the
development teams get
into this really rapid pace.
But then, because
they can't actually
get their applications all
the way out into production,
that it all gets
wadded up around that.
So we prefer to
think of operations
as being the place to start
with this kind of technology.
We will talk about our
engagement here a bit more.
So the customer we're
going to talk about today
is a company called Zonar.
They are in the
industrial IOT space,
have a long-running
business, lots and lots
of devices, lots and
lots of customers.
And again, Lee's going to
talk about that a bit more.
But to give you a sense for--
like, how does a
project like this really
get started from
the executive level?
The place that we decided
would be a great place for us
to engage is around
disaster recovery refresh
in the light of
public cloud options.
So we said, we'll analyze
those options for you.
We'll look at risks.
We'll embed our
team with your team
to make sure we really
understand what's going on.
We'll build some
small experiments.
And then we'll re-plan
based on doing that.
So with that, Lee, why
don't you come on up?
And I don't know if you
want to leave slide here.
Great.
Thanks.
LEE CHANG: Hello.
Thanks, Bob.
And thanks, Craig.
I know we keep shifting around.
So I hope you guys could
keep track of who's who.
So I know you all were
listening really intently
to what Craig talked about
with regards to containers
and running services
in Kubernetes.
Because what I'm going
to be talking about--
and convince you,
hopefully, that--
taking these concepts,
you can actually
do it in the real world.
And what we did was Zonar, which
is what Bob mentioned, was we
analyzed-- so I don't know
if Bob talked about this.
But what our project was was to
do a disaster recovery refresh
with Zonar.
They had systems that
were currently running.
They were looking at probably
modernizing the systems--
I should probably put
this in my pocket--
and also trying to
see what they needed
to do to add to their
business continuity plan.
One of the things that they
wanted to bring to the table
was potentially
moving to the cloud.
At Samsung CNCT, we have a
lot of engineers on staff
who've actually have done
a lot of lift and shift
from on-prem systems into
the cloud, VMs, containers.
Like Bob mentioned, we've
been doing Kubernetes
since the get go.
So it's been about
two-some odd years
that we're working with
Kubernetes, and also
containers.
We did containers,
actually, a few years ago
before that with Cloud Foundry.
There could be arguments if
that's containers or not.
But that's moving small
packets into the cloud.
So we have a lot of
experience with that.
And Zonar, knowing that we were
such subject-matter experts,
they brought us in, had us look
over some of their systems that
were running in their
secondary data center--
which was their disaster
recovery system--
and give them some options on
potentially moving that system
to the cloud-- not all
of it, maybe part of it.
But what we did was,
like Bob mentioned,
we had our teams of
embedded with their teams.
This was a nice place
to be because they
were only two blocks away
from our office in Seattle.
It's not that we
don't like traveling,
but it's great to be able
to just go down there.
If you needed to
do deep dives, you
need to analyze their systems,
is just two blocks away.
So we could go over
there for five minutes.
What we did was did some POCs.
We looked at their stack.
We made sure that what
we were going to do
was always going to be feasible.
So mostly what we're
looking out for was,
did they have any proprietary
systems that prevent them
from moving to the clouds?
So if they needed network
equipment that was proprietary,
or they needed systems that
needed to be run on bare metal.
Luckily, none of that was there.
So it was a lot simpler
story to say that we
could move to containers.
Since we are here to listen to
people talk about containers
and Kubernetes, the
question wasn't if they
could move to the cloud.
The question actually was,
where can you run Kubernetes?
Because we went
through the steps.
We figured that containers
was a viable option for them.
So where can we run Kubernetes?
Kubernetes is in our DNA.
We've worked with
Google since day one.
They were already using
Google Container Engine.
I forgot to tell you,
this was about a year ago.
So we followed
closely that project.
And we realized,
this is probably
the best place for them
to move their systems
for the secondary data center.
Part of the benefits
of using GKE--
since we've been using
Kubernetes for a while,
we understand any cluster
that you want to operate,
there's operational
loads, start-up costs,
putting your staff
through training
to understand how you're
going to run a new cluster.
It's different than what
they had in on-prem.
And the other thing
is, what are you
going to do for
building a new cluster?
They had business that
were running currently
servicing customer
needs, bringing in money.
How are they going
to extend that?
This is what they were trying to
do with their new data center.
They needed to extend that.
They were getting more business.
So how do you not increase
more in your capital costs?
So Kubernetes, again, with GKE
was a great solution for that.
And another thing that they had
with-- after many, many years,
15 plus years, of operating
a data center on-prem,
they had expertise to do that.
So GKE is using Kubernetes
underneath any place
that you can run Kubernetes,
whether it be on-prem
or in the cloud.
So we can use Kubernetes
running on GKE very easily.
A little bit of context of
what the customer was running.
It was a classic N-tier
system, three tiers.
You had the web tier
application tier.
You had the middle tier,
and a database back end.
The database transactions,
or the business transactions,
were spread across multiple
PostgreSQL database servers.
They had about 100
database servers running.
All their application systems,
and middle tier and databases
systems were running on VM.
90% of it was VMs all running
on bare metal in their data
center, and also in their
secondary data center.
They had a large installed
base of head units.
So their business was
running head units, 450,000,
500,000 head units that
were basically IOT systems.
And what they did was take
sensory data, telemetry data,
sent that back through the
internet to their data center
to do the processing and
do reports off of that.
The traffic that was
resulting from that
was all run through
their network appliances.
So the load balancing
network route switchers
were all hardwared running
in their data centers.
And the majority of all their
data that was landing on files
was all stored on network
attach source systems.
And 200 terabytes
of data was being
stored remotely from
their database servers
in their on-prem data centers.
So again, it was pointed
out that their dev
teams were excited about
moving forward fast.
Some of them had
experience with containers.
So there was a big
drive to say, hey,
if we're going to move
forward, let's see
if we can use containers
in the new solution
that we're providing for them.
So that is a great plus.
We didn't have to do a lot
of convincing on their side
to get them to move to a
container-type environment.
So what we came up with, a
model that we can go with--
and I forgot my pointer.
So I'm going to have to
do a lot hand waving here.
Their current system,
their current data center,
and their secondary center,
consisted of the head units--
400,000 to 500,000 head units
that go through the internet
and send their telemetry
data to their current data
center in Seattle.
So they had their gateway.
The load balancers were
all physical appliances.
Web servers running on bare
metal, and VMs, and database
servers.
So the new system using
the Google Direct Connect
through our partner, which
was a 10 GigE low latency,
since we're using the
central location, about 40
to 50 milliseconds connected
to the Cloud Connect using
cloud load balancing.
If any of you have used
Kubernetes and Angular, you all
realize, if you
want services that
need to talk to a
Kubernetes resource,
you need to use a load balance.
So Cloud Load Balancer was
a great solution for that.
Container engines-- since
this is a GKE solution,
we used Container Engine.
Persistent disk to backup
back any systems that
needed stateful files.
And we use Google Container
Registry for all the Docker
images that were built.
It's a great product.
It's co-load with your cluster,
so you get really fast response
times.
And also we were able to
leverage the IAM system,
so the security
was there built in.
The process that we did to move
them from their current data
center, or their secondary data
center and their primary data
centers, to the cloud, we
used a lot of our own tools,
called K2, K2-CI, which is
our automatic delivery system.
Those consisted of other tools.
We took a lot of
open source projects.
We also used Google's Cloud CLI.
And brought that up to do
some lifecycle management.
One of the biggest tools
that we use from Google--
and we got this sort of
free, free as in beer.
You still have to pay for
some of the transactions.
But we leveraged the
ability to use Stackdriver
for logging and monitoring.
This actually contributed to
reducing the operational load
on the teams, in that
they didn't have to create
another monitoring system.
Now there's going to be
some swivel chairing.
People are going
argue, well, you've
got some swivel chairing
went back and forth.
But the benefits of having
a system that's pre-built,
that's running automatically--
there's like a flag or some
command line you
could add to it--
and able to get all
the feedback real time.
And also, monitoring
was a big benefit.
As mentioned before, automation,
automation, automation
is really important.
We used a pipeline called CAIC--
we need a new name for this.
I'm sorry-- K2-CI
Application Delivery Pipeline
to do our automated building,
and testing, and deployment
of applications to GKE.
So what we started with was
production-quality artifacts
from Zonar, binaries
that were already going
to their production systems.
We took any changes
from there and put them
into this deployment pipeline.
We could also use source code.
But in this case, we used
their binary artifacts
from their artifact system and
packaged that with Docker files
and Helm charts.
So Craig talked about
Helm charts back
in his previous talk.
We use Helm charts as
the delivery mechanism.
So everything was
wrapped in Helm charts
that's within the source code.
Any changes there were
reflected in the Helm charts.
And actually, what
Helm charts provide
you is the ability to
say, this is the state
that I expect Kubernetes to be
running this application, which
is really nice for us.
We also use Helm charts to
codify manage services outside
of Google Container
Engine itself.
We have dependent resources that
are running in Google Cloud.
We didn't want to have
a separate mechanism
or a configuration
system that we
needed to run in addition
to our pipeline system.
So we actually
codify and managed
that in Kubernetes charts.
So those usually included, the
cloud load-balancer solution,
the networking cloud solution,
and the cloud DNS solution
that's provided by Google.
So those were all managed
to Helm charts, which really
simplified the pipeline itself.
Database, so I know
Craig, in his slide,
had a big, red
maybe on databases.
We've been doing this
for a number of years.
Our teams have done a
lot of lifts and shifts
on open source databases,
from MySQL to PostgreSQL.
And the answer to this
is, yes, you could do it.
Previously, with VMs, it was
a little bit more complicated,
and sometimes more hairy with
the wiring and everything
you had to do in the
back end systems.
Actually, let me backup.
So there was
questions asked to us,
why don't we use
a hosted solution?
Google announced their
PostgreSQL solution today--
yesterday.
RDS is probably one
of the biggest things
that people know about.
They have PostgreSQL
running in RDS.
So why don't we use them?
It's a Cadillac solution.
It gives you all
the nice benefits
of redundancy and
automated failovers.
The biggest reason
why is the customer,
Zonar, actually uses
proprietary extensions.
Their business, a lot
of the domain logic,
uses proprietary
PostgreSQL extensions.
So asking their development
team to refactor that, put that
into the middle tier, was
pretty much out of the question
because they needed
this project done
at a relatively rapid manner.
So hosting and using
our own database
was really the
only path forward.
So we said yes to
the question, can we
do the lift and shift
for the database server.
This caused consternation,
a lot of debates.
But we prototyped this
and proved that it worked.
And again, Kubernetes
really benefited us in this.
We used stateful services
and Persistent Volumes
using Persistent
disks off Google.
Google-- I don't know
if you all know this--
the bigger the disk, the better
IOPS, the better latency,
and all that good stuff,
which was really nice compared
to products out there--
compared to other cloud
providers out there.
So you have your on-prem system
with the database running
on bare metal, and
your data landing
on the network-attached storage.
Or we had a stream
of application
going through the
internet over the big pipe
that we had configured and
provisioned with Google
to Cloud Interconnect
Load Balancer.
So that could talk specifically
to one database server running
in a pod as a stateful pod.
And that guaranteed that the
disk that eventually gets
created with the data file--
if that pod goes
away, stateful service
brings it up and
does all the wiring
for you, which made
life really simple.
When you first try to do
these things, when you're
showing the customer that
this can take the load based
on your calculations,
it's not going to do that.
So if it doesn't do
it, five minutes later,
spin something up with a
bigger resource requirement.
The quota gets
increased, and boom.
You can just change
your wall files.
Everything just syncs
up, hopefully, magically.
But if it doesn't
work, you could
spend another day doing that.
Versus a VM, where you
have to reconfigure,
rewire all the database
files in the back end.
So this really helped us
show that the customer can
run their workload over in
the cloud fairly simply.
The pipeline itself, now this
is not a literal representation
of our pipeline.
If I had that chart up here,
it if even was landscaped,
it would be wall-to-wall,
a bunch of flows,
and a bunch of arrows
going all over the place.
So this is a very
high-level, probably
100,000 [? file ?] view.
The way it worked was--
I wish I had my pointer.
So we took production artifacts
from their systems on-prem.
Any changes there, the
pipeline picked it up,
pushed that change
through Docker Build
into the Google
Container Registry.
That updates the tag
inside the Helm chart.
And there might be other
changes to Helm chart,
but we'll simplify that
and say there isn't.
Once those changes are
detected, we do a Helm install,
the pipeline does.
It goes into a
staging environment.
The staging environment
is created on demand.
So that way, if you
need another test,
you're not going to
pollute that environment
with the previous test.
If the staging
environment test passed,
the conformance test passes.
And if this is the one
that goes to production,
you do a Helm upgrade.
And the reason why you do a Helm
upgrade versus a Helm install
is you don't want to affect
any resources or objects that
are already running
on that cluster.
Helm [? uninstall ?] only
does changes inside opponent.
So it only makes changes
to things that are actually
changed within either the Helm
chart, or the artifact itself.
So if you have load balancers,
you have stateful services.
And if you have
applications out there,
it'll do a rolling update.
But the load balancers and
network connection DNSs,
those don't get
changed or get deleted
if those changes aren't
reflected inside the Helm
chart.
So some of the things that we
ran into during this process,
with any type of trying
to understand applications
from the outside, it
could take a while
to figure out the
domain logic, also
what replicating applications.
One of the things that
we also ran into--
but this is not something
that we've never
seen before-- is VMs
could become bloated.
You get monoliths at times.
They had the classic
monolith, where
they had database is running--
I'm sorry.
In the VM, they actually had
databases running their caching
solutions.
And they had web
applications that
were run, Nginx,
Tomcat, RabbitMQ,
and their Memcache systems.
We, with Kubernetes, was able
to refactor that pretty quickly,
put the applications
in single container,
and just use pods to manage
that, do all the wiring,
and the networking for that.
There's also some lack
of management tools.
Kubernetes is
still pretty young.
It's about two years old.
So given any new
project, there might
be a lack of tools of
lifecycle management.
But we have K2 with the years
of experience that we've had.
We have K2, K2-CI.
So we have those tools
already built in-house.
That leverages a lot of
open source tools there.
Some of the wins that
Zonar experienced
doing the [? post ?]
process was they
are able to use the pipeline
in conjunction with GKE
and really speed up their
productivity, not just with
the disaster recovery solution.
They were able to get
containers out faster,
databases out faster,
changing their schemas.
Everything was just
a lot more quicker.
GKE also reduced the
operational load.
I think I covered
that a bunch of times.
Not having to operate
a cluster by hand,
we were able to depend on
Google's-- or Zonar was able
to depend on Google's Site
Reliability engineers to do
the control plane act
management itself.
And containerizing
their applications,
they experienced better
scalability running on GKE.
Scalability-- and not that
when disaster happens,
and they move all their
traffic to the cloud,
and they cannot respond
faster to production load,
but they can also now be
portable across different
infrastructures.
So they can run that
container-- kind
of what Craig described-- one
application that's running
in the container in the cloud.
They could run locally on
their own personal laptops
using Minikube.
Or they could also
run on on-prem systems
if they have a Kubernetes
cluster running on-prem.
And they can also run in
other hosting solutions,
and/or they could run another
cluster in themselves.
GKE is really easy to start.
Two command line commands,
boom, you got your own cluster
up and running.
Do another Helm install.
Helm install is available
through the repo.
And you could deploy another
environment pretty much
at whim.
Some of the takeaways I
hope you get from this,
you can adapt any
application stack--
and I'm using the word
any-- to move to the cloud
without major refactoring.
And some of the benefits
that we went through--
and I went through
this really fast,
but you can run GKE and
on-prem in a hybrid model.
So you don't have to lift and
shift everything all at once.
You can have services
running in your on-prem
and have services
running in a cloud still
talking to your
on-prem as long as you
have a nice direct
connect provisioned.
Or we actually
have VPNs running.
So as long as it's not
full database traffic,
you're able to actually run it
in a hybrid model using GKE.
Classic IT and Cloud
Native can be on the cloud.
So both systems, you can
definitely run in the cloud.
And originally, when we were
first doing some cost analysis,
this project versus them
doing a data center refresh
in their secondary
data center, what
would the costs
of spanning that,
refreshing their gear
there versus building out
the cloud using our services to
do the life and shift for them?
They were actually saving
money by bringing us
in to help them do
the lift and shift,
and also paying for
the Google services.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
CRAIG BOX: Thank you.
All right, thank
you, Lee and Bob.
So in conclusion, very
quickly, three distinct changes
we see here.
Package your applications
and containers.
Make them work in clusters.
And then deploy
them to the cloud.
Here's a tweet I saw
a couple of days ago,
which really sums
this process up.
So one guy, six months to move
from an RPM-based deployment
platform using Docker
CI, Kubernetes,
doing continuous
deploy to Kubernetes.
And took the deployment
process for the VPN software
from 8 hours to three minutes.
Thank you very much.
[MUSIC PLAYING]